now on to washington we go and the
latest in a series of revelations about
the justice department
under former president trump cbs news
has learned the department subpoenaed
personal data of at least
two democrats on the house intelligence
committee in 2017 and
in 2018. now at the time attorney
general jeff sessions was looking into
leaks
of classified information about contacts
between russia
and the president's aides the subpoenas
were first reported last night by the
new york times
cbs news senior investigative
correspondent there she is catherine
herridge joins us now
with more on the story good morning to
you catherine what's been the reaction
on capitol hill so far
gail good morning the reaction has been
one of anger especially among democrats
who say
this is another example of what they
call the trump administration's assault
on democracy
and using the justice department as its
own political weapon
against his opponents it's not clear
what leaks the justice department was
pursuing
but media reports about top trump aids
conversations
with russian officials were frequent
during the transition
and after he became president the new
york times reported that the justice
department in 2017
under sessions and again in 2018
subpoenaed apple and an unnamed company
for the communications
metadata of at least a dozen people
connected to the house intelligence
committee
cbs news has confirmed the doj
subpoenaed the records
of democratic congressman adam schiff
and eric swalwell
as well as aides family members and even
a minor
all in an attempt to find the leaker
congressman schiff now the committee's
chairman and swalwell confirmed
their data was seized last night and
called for an immediate investigation
although the metadata did not tie any
committee members to the leaks
sessions successor bill barr revived the
investigation
in 2019. the intelligence committee
received confirmation in may of this
year
that the investigation had been closed a
senior adviser to president
trump had no comment to share when asked
whether the former president knew
or even ordered subpoenas of the phone
records both apple and the department of
justice
declined our requests for comment
catherine herridge thank you catherine